still getting into the flow here with
his new team five-point lead for the
Thunder Gorge straight away and that's
what he's been doing from three-point
territory this week we'll start here
they lead by ten Devil ears led by Terry
day in the previous game this would be
mean service Russell style now remember
we told you that they're an excellent
defensive teams here a little below
eight points per game you know it's
interesting almost the same amount of
shots from the Oregon and that's a shot
that Carmelo Anthony rarely misses the
Lakers twelve point lead for the Thunder
Thomas nice lob by Adams look out here
and a fast-break opportunity Westbrook
to the cop got it to fall hello
I'd advantage against JR Smith well what
a move by club no away but he how many
times have we seen that welcome I not
see could do it on either Sarge came
down and he was behind the backboard and
he maneuvered out meeting LeBron James
George for three got another one both
George with his fourth 3-ball of the
afternoon he left it short in Westbrook
another rebound whispers OH
just got to read it whirlwind of the day
high-stepping with the left hand
finished that's his third I struck off
the screen kicks it out to George
nobody's been able to contain Paul
George here in the Holmes town and he is
vaporizing that Cleveland defense of
flora okay with walls that are not
hitting the rims they've hit the side of
the backboard his Weiss and shot an air
ball once and Melo is starting to heat
up it's LeBron James pitch it to the
corner the extra pass the catch and
shoot to Melo
that's great looking offense you'd be
brown from head coach tyloo saying that
he's passed up a lot of shots this year
that we don't want him to pass up Paul
George not passing up much if any here
he's got 29 now on their defensive porch
11 to 2 Westbrook with the three-point
play coming up is it not a lot of blocks
and their 21st in steals their were all
bad numbers that which dictate how your
defense goes and those numbers looking
even worse today with the hot shooting
of Carmelo Anthony now with 23 points